how to reach a million people with your
book if you're an author if you have an
idea or if you have a business that you
want to reach a lot of people you want
to reach a million people you need to
create a movement this has to be
important you have to have a message
that is worth spreading
this isn't going to be you talking about
a few conferences doing a little bit of
media you need people to want to spread
this thing for you it's not just going
to be you standing up there talking you
need to create a powerful movement your
book your idea your company needs to
stand for something super important and
if I were you if I was trying to create
this movement I would start by studying
movements that already exist model
success find people who have done this
before look at Martin Luther King he
created a powerful movement what was it
all about
one word what's one word you explain
Martin Luther King's movement about
equality and for people who were not
given that equality for black people in
America who were not treated as equals
who were looked down as second-class
citizens that meant something to them
that meant something extremely powerful
and extremely emotional that got them to
move and it wasn't just black people
there's a lot of white people who felt
that it was wrong the way black people
are being treated that meant something
to them too if you look at how did he
get all those people on Capitol Hill how
did he get so many people that come to
Capitol Hill to listen to him he didn't
have a website he didn't have
newsletters he wasn't running a
pay-per-click campaign he wasn't forcing
it out people were spreading the message
for him because it was powerful because
it meant something deep and meaningful
to them your message has to be that
important if you want people to spread
it for you and if you look at the people
who came out something like 25 to 30
percent of the people who showed up were
white this wasn't just for black people
this for anybody who believed that
people need to be treated equally it's
powerful of breaks barriers you're not
just pitching
one community so what's your message
what are you trying to change in the
world and what is something that can hit
people here make them feel something so
they'll share it think about the stuff
that you share now okay think about the
stuff that you share with your friends
you post on Facebook you see something
you have to tell the world about it
either your friends on an email or your
spreaded in social media whatever things
that you share it's something that hit
you so then I hit you hard I'm not
talking about the silly cat videos
you'll share that stuff too
but the stuff that means something to
you you see a picture or a short video
or something something that hits you you
feel like you want to share it because
you want to share your jour you want to
share that passion and so you tell
people about it you do it yourself you
understand how to share what you need to
do is create that message create that
video create that picture create that
book that is so powerful that has such a
serious impact that people can't help
but share it because all the newsletters
and pay-per-click ads all of that stuff
it's not going to help you you're not
going to build a movement from that it's
not going to be you forcing your message
down people's throats it's got to be
something that they have been waiting to
hear something that they have been
waiting for somebody to rise up and be
the spokesperson and leave the charge
for this cause that needs to be you it
has to be that powerful that's be that
important if you want to create a
movement you want to impact a million
people this in response to a question I
came in from one of my newsletter
readers Yvonne who has a book and she
said I have an objective of reaching 1
million hearts with my one tip book how
do I set up my campaign I'm going to a
publisher the publisher has his part I
have my part what should I do
first of all I don't know what this is
all about what's your one tip book what
is the message right that's got tools
out of everything that you're doing
you have to passion believe in it and I
believe that you do is just not being
communicated don't rely on your
publisher ok your publisher doesn't get
this publishers don't know how to create
movements when was the last time a
publisher created a movement it doesn't
happen the whole
market.you but barely and that's not
what they understand this is on you this
is on you connecting with people
connecting deeply with people connecting
in a way that nobody has connected with
them about something that is so critical
vital important to them what is that I
can't even speak about this book because
you didn't let me know in your message
what it's all about one tip is great it
sounds simple but what's your message I
have to believe in it I have to love it
I have to see a sample of it and want to
share that you got to hit me with
something so hard and I'm not saying hit
it like throw it in my face hit it but
hit it hit me here with a simple message
that's easy to spread that I'm gonna
want to get up and make a video about it
because when I see great businesses I'd
make a video about it if I see a great
message I share it I put it on my
Facebook and my Twitter my blog and I
send it out I share with my audience so
you have to give me something worth
sharing and give other people something
worth sharing the message has to be that
important so figure out what it is
including everything that you're doing
and work on building your movement
that's how you're going to help reach a
million people and beyond and not just
reach them you're gonna change their
lives at least I hope that's what you're
gonna do I hope that's what your goal is
that's why you should be doing this
it's not just for people to pick up your
book you want to help them and as an
entrepreneur I don't care if you're
selling a book or not you have an idea
you have a company it should be to make
the world a better place and you should
want to have as big an impact as you can
change as many lives as you can and
that's gonna start with creating the
movement around something that you
believe powerfully in that nobody has
stepped up and become the leader on and
you're gonna say people follow me
believe in this and we will ride to the
promised land together believe
for those of you watching you like this
video please give it a thumbs up below
it makes gonna do more for you and I
want to hear from you
leave a comment underneath you like this
video put it below you have a question
for your company leave it below make a
video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon